done
はぁんっ
はぁんっん
[音楽]
ん
me
今日は気難しいはずの物理学者の桧山と申します
今日は a 棟物理吐息難しいお話をやめにして皆さんに分かりやすいお話をしたいな
というふうに思っています
皆さんこう思えませんか夜中には常識とかけ離れた
突飛な発想からまぁ色々な面白いいわゆる
ブレイクスルーだとか
イノベーションというの子3打差生み出されるということがあると思います
または逆の発想逆のアプローチから色々なブレークスルーが生まれるイノベーションを
生まれるということ
例えば
これは自動車の大量生産です
100年前は
いわゆるその
沢山のこの車これに人が11移動して自動車の部品を組み立てるということを行ってき
ました
しかしそれでは非常に効率が悪いです
次の逆の発想というのが生まれます
これは9
を逆に動かすこれがベルトコンベアの始まりです
そうすることによって今度は人が人を動かさず車が動いてそれに人が
くらい張り付いて部品を作っていくと
そういうことによって自動車の大量生産が生まれました
こういうふうに逆向きの発想というのが実社会に非常に大きな役割を担います
実はこの逆向きの発想というのは我々科学の世界においても同様でいろいろな
ブレークスルーを生み出します
この話を私の実際の研究を紹介しながらお話をしていきたいというふうに思っています
今年の物理学賞ノーベル物理学賞は
ワールブラックホールの衝突からの重力波を検証するということです
これは実は100年前にあっアインシュタインが予言をしていました
で今100年経ってこの世界でこの検証をまぬあたりにするということは非常に役科学
者として嬉しいことです
この後に実は中性子星というものの合体をしてそこから出てくる重力波というのが検証
されました
実はこの中性性そのものにも大きな謎があります我々科学者はこの中性子星というもの
に今非常な興味を持っています
では中世というのはどういうものなのかということをお話ししていきたいとおもいます
私たちのここにいる宇宙というのは138億年前にビッグバーによって生まれました
その後10億年経って星が生まれます
星の一生というのは生まれたときに対応の実は8倍を
バウンダーにして限界にして
運命が変わります
宇宙のそのえっ小さい星いわゆるたい48馬油でも小さい星というのはその後白色矮星
になって静かに燃え尽きていきます
太陽の質量の8梅雨大きい星はその後超新星爆発をして星のない分はブラックホールか
中性子星になります
この中のこの中節制というものに
われわれは非常に今興味を持っています
この中性子星がどのくらいの大きさかと言いますと直径が20キロぐらいですそれは
ここである江南キャンパスを中心にしてだいたい三宮の駅まで届くぐらいの大きさです
そんなに小さな星なんですけれども実はこの最大の質量非常に大きくて
実は太陽の1.5倍もあります
このことは実は宇宙の教科書にはちゃんと書いてあって
我々科学者の常識として捉えています
しかしながら2010年に恐ろしいことを置きました
なんと教科書を塗り替えるということが起きたのです
それは太陽のにバイト質量がサイダーに資料であるということが実はわかったんです
でこのことは我々科学者は最大の驚きをもって迎えました皆さんから見ると1.5から
2倍になったところでなんでもないじゃないかっていうふうに思うかもしれません
けれども
我々理論家は実はこの庁次長式だと思われている対応の1.5倍というものを
実は理論で
説明しようと思っていろいろ努力を積み重ねてきました
でも下手な d ドンを使うともう簡単に対応必要に1.1倍1.2倍という風になっ
て1.5倍までなかなか到達しない
そういう努力を積み重ねていたところに2010年さらにかけ離れた
2倍という値を保ってきた
わけです我々はかなりショックを受けて未だに覚えてるんですけど夜も眠れませんでし
た
われわれはこれを大の必要に灰をどうやって解決したらいいのかということが非常に
大きな関心ごととして今まさにホットな話題という風になっています
ではこの対応の必要2倍である
悪中世性というのは何でできているのかと言いますと
読んで字のごとくたくさんの中性子
そして少しの要旨そしてハイペロンと呼ばれる地球上には存在しない有志でできている
というふうに言われています
この研究をするためには
実はインプットとしてこの容姿と中性子の間の力そしてハイペロンと用紙の間の力また
はこの赤と白の間の力というのがインプットとして重要です
しかしながらこれまでは実はこの白と青の間の力ということは分かってきていました
ところが赤と青または赤と白の間の力というのは実はこれまでよく分かっていません
でした
でも抽選制の祭壇に中3杯を解き明かすためにはどうしても個の力というのが
重要です一つの解決の糸口としては一つありうるのはこの中性子星を人工的に地球で
作るということが一つ考えられます
しかし皆さん考えてみてください太陽の必要2倍も大きな星をこの小さな地球でつくる
って危険だと思いません
ちょっと間違っ
ブラックホールになるかもしれない
そんなことを科学者をやってはいけないわけです
そうするとここでまた逆向きの発想が生まれます
ホンダ中性子星そのものを細く細く小さく見ていきましょう
そうすると細かく見ていった最初の最小単位というのはこの容姿と中性子
そしてはいピロ3つの粒子でできていますこの3つの漁師
もしくは
この4つの粒子というのを人工的に作るということを考えます
このハエペロンと容姿と中性子星できている原子核をハイパー書くというふうに読め
ます
このハイパー各はこの加速器施設というところで人工的に作ります
でこの加速器施設で作ったこのハイパー角を理論的にこの構造を解き明かすということ
を行うわけです
でこの中でハイペロンと洋室を中性子
3つの粒子でできていますこれを我々は3大問題というふうに思います
また4つの粒子でできているものを4大問題というふうに言います
この3対4大問題を理論で解き明かすということを行うわけです
で数えられますよねさん体温たいというふうに
しかしながら3大問題4大問題を理論的に解くということは非常に難しいんです
これは何で難しいのかということを次の人間社会を捉えてお話ししていきましょう
例えば仲の良いお友達同士で何か物事を決めようという風に考えたとすると
気心が知れているのでマアムのこと比較的簡単に決まるかというふうに思います
けれどそこにひとり気難しい人がちょっと好きじゃない人が例えばやってくると思い
ます
これ三大問題です
そうすると先ほど決まりやすかった物事が途端に複雑になってくるということは皆さん
も経験があるかと思います
ここにもう1人また気難しい人が入ってくるとしますこれ4大問題です
さらに難しくなってきますよね先ほど
に大問題だったら決まりやすかったことが4大問題になったことでお子はさになるとか
そういうことも経験終わりかと思います実はこの子とミクロの世界で
も同じです非常にた大問題になってくると複雑怪奇になってきます
これを数式で表すと途端に寝始める人がいるかもしれませんがこのような数式を明かす
ということになります
この中でこの部位とあるのがインプットで先ほど言いました力というものです
そしてこの式を解き明かして b トップサイトある記号
これがアウトプットで解き明かすもんですこれが実は実験と比較することが可能です
こういった式をきっちりと解き明かしていいとプサイを出すというのが実は私の研究の
目的の一つです
こういった問題を解くときにこれまではこの力というものが確実にきちっと与えられれ
ば先ほどの四季をしっかり磨いてアウトプットを出しそして実験と比較するということ
がこれまでできました
ところが実はこの力という今回のものができなかった場合
一体どうしたらいいんでしょうかアウトプットが出せません
こういった問題実は時のしたわけです
そこで考えついたのが逆向きの発送です
つまりどういうことかと言いますと私のし
問題数式をきっちり解けます従ってよくわかっていない力というのをとにかく使って
しっかりと口ということをします
でそれをアウトプットとして実験と比較
検討しますそうすることから実は逆向き日からに修正を与えることができます
そうしてできた力信頼できる力を今度は抽選制の研究というところにインプットとして
与えるということを思いついたわけです
こういうこういう今のプロジェクトを行うことによって今先ほど言いました
中性子星のタイ王室の2倍という謎
これを解き明かすということも間もなくというふうに我々は
感じているところです
最後になりましたが今日話したのこの逆向けの発送
逆向きのアプローチです
我々科学の社会でもこの客向きのアプローチを考えることによって様々な解決の糸口と
いうのがあっちゅう間に広がるということを経験します
このことは実は我々カークの世界だけじゃなくて実社会においても重要なことだと思い
ます
例えば皆さん新しいプロジェクトを立ち上げるということをしようと思うと
必ず何か問題にぶち当たる壁に当たるということは経験はあるかと思いますその壁を
乗り越える時に正面トッパーをするとか正攻法でいくことでたまたまだとかそういう
ことで解決するということは
よくあると思いますでもうまくいかないことだってあると思います
そういう時はちょっと別の視点で見る逆向きの発想で考えてみる
そうしたことで今まで難しかったことがあっという間に解決するということはよくある
と思います
皆さんがこれから新しい課題にどんどん挑戦していくことだというふうに思います
もし壁にぶち当たった時に思い出してみてください
この逆向きの発送逆向きのアプローチですどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]